Ramanujan is an inspirational figure. After
all, he’s the topic of a popular Hollywood
film now, The Man Who Knew Infinity. But he’s
much more than an inspirational figure to
me. He’s been a guardian angel to me. And
as impossible as that might sound, to believe,
I have to tell you he was — the news of
Ramanujan was very important to me as a 16-year
old. As a 16-year-old high-schooler I was
trained that — I was trained to believe
that to be successful you had to be a perfect,
straight-A student. You had to get perfect
test scores. Of course they’re important,
but Mrs. Ramanujan wrote a letter to my father
in 1984 when I was in 10th grade over 60 years
after Ramanujan died. And that’s I when first
learned about this great genius who was not
well known for grades. If anything he was
well known for being a two-time college dropout,
but a real artist, a genius, someone who’s
mathematical ideas were pure flights of fancy.
I learned about him again in college when
the NOVA special about him came out. And Professor
Paul Sally, one of my most important mentors
in my life, came along and we talked about
Ramanujan and the importance of his ideas.
And then of course in graduate when the book
The Man Who Knew Infinity came out, together
with my adviser Basil Gordon, we read it and
we got a lot of strength out of it. At least
certainly I did. And certainly at those three
points in my life — as a high school student,
and a college student and later as a graduate
student — I needed to be reminded and reassured
that the time was going to come that I would
be evaluated professionally for my achievement
and not test scores and not grades. And in
that way I think he’s been my guardian angel
and you know in my work I’ve been following
him professionally and it’s worked out very
well for me.